Cesar believes in the power of the pack
but he also knows that any grouping of
dogs needs a calm assertive pack leader
to guide them Chuy had a great
relationship with somebody can really
care less he wants mom and he's actually
two pack later too but the relationship
was phenomenal we couldn't ask for more
so there were about they were a pack
they were an amazing perfect uh-huh
him and car might start fighting
Chihuahua versus Jack Russell yeah he
turns around latches on to my hand
oh sure his arm and Jack was hanging
from it yeah all the way down to the
bone get out of here
but these fights that happen for no
reason
oh it is a reason well that we can't
figure out oh let's talk about exercise
they can exercise yeah we walk more yeah
how I will walk them for half an hour 45
minutes we'll take them and put them in
the car and take them down to different
parks thirty minutes might be a lot to
you but not a lot to them right the
physical challenge is not enough to
drain you know so they don't hit zero
they have gone to a state of mind that
has no limits you will have two dogs who
have gone to red zone in that only red
zone he redirects the energy towards the
owner who loves him very much the thing
is you can't do this yourself they have
to start this life brand new somewhere
else which it makes it easier for them
it's like detox they're so addictive to
kill each other and just changing the
environment changed the state of mind
for that moment Cesar decides that Jack
and carmine need to join his pack to
rehabilitate their aggressive behavior
almost three weeks later demo and
Rebecca arrived at the dog psychology
center with their two combatants you
hear what's happening outside ward
alright guys so we got to put this guys
in there yeah okay now you hold this one
right here I'm gonna control that one
over Hey
so you just have to stop the intensity
you see it mm-hmm two kids in one place
they're gonna fight one of the grown-ups
have to represent authority figure
I see how you sold in the leash relax
your past intention okay those little
bitty things is communication with it
with an animal you are constantly
communicating understand pass it to me
you